on va parler dans quelques uns quand cet
instant des conséquences pour les
collectivités mais pour les français
puisque évidemment les français sont
inquiets sk est longue lettre est ce que
c'est parti pour durer cette crise
énergétique
oui ça c'est sûr que c'est parti pour
durer que l'énergie va rester cher
pendant des années il ya des raisons
pour appeler conjoncturel la sortie du
coc vis de la crise en ukraine mais dans
tous les cas de façon tendancielle on
savait que les prix de l'énergie à
l'augmenter là on a eu un gros gros boum
donc il faut s'attendre à ce que ça
continue d'être élevée et puis si on
parle là des particuliers mais c'est
vrai pour les collectivités le ministre
de l'économie le 10 1 il va y avoir des
hausses alors certes contenu mais des
hausses quand même dans les mois à venir
en tout cas au début de l'année
prochaine donc oui ça c'est certain que
les prix vont rester à des niveaux
extrêmement élevés dans les années à
venir et le gouvernement pourra
continuer
on va pouvoir maintenir un bouclier
tarifaire aussi imposant que celui qu'on
a aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai qu'on
ne s'en rend pas vraiment compte parce
que le bouclier est arrivé avant qu'on
ait les hausses massives alors ceux qui
se chauffent au gaz ont quand même déjà
vu au cours de l'année 2000 21 des
hausses importantes un des hausses à
deux chiffres mais c'est vrai que là
depuis ces derniers mois grâce au
bouclier tarifaire la hausse a été
réellement contenu elle a été quand même
2 4% assez important pour de nombreux
ménages mais que 4% se seraient 30 à 40%
si jamais on n'avait pas eu ce bouclier
tarifaire on le voit là par exemple en
allemagne les allemands sont en train de
recevoir leurs factures en ce moment les
prix sont à des niveaux extrêmement
élevés donc ce n'est pas possible
sûrement sur le long terme de garder un
bouclier aussi efficace est la grande
question ça m qu'est ce que ça veut dire
des hausses contenu parce que le mot
qu'il faudrait utiliser ces des hausses
acceptable et on se connaît déjà la
difficulté d'un bon nombre de ménages à
la précarité énergétique elle existait
avant que les prix soit élevé donc on
sait que pour beaucoup de ménages il ya
des difficultés financières déjà élevé
chaque hiver en raison
des prix de lait de l'énergie ouais
inquiétudes sur la sur la hausse des
prix frédéric inquiétude également aussi
sur est ce qu'on aura assez d'énergie
cet hiver est ce que le risque de black
out existe vraiment oui puisse un risque
était théorisé depuis des années parce
que l'état ça fait 30 ans que l'état n'a
pas de stratégie en matière d'énergie ça
fait que trente ans que l'état dit on
arrête le nucléaire où on freine une
relance que l'état dit faut lancer les
énergies renouvelables sauf que les îles
les énergies renouvelables n'ont pas été
vraiment lancé pis personne n'a vraiment
envie donc mécaniquement à mesure que la
baisse de la production nucléaire est
enclenché et qui a toujours pas la
hausse des énergies alternatives
forcément il arrivera un moment où on
aura un blackout mois dans un bouquin ya
très longtemps je l'avais prédit pour
2030 on en sera peut-être pas en 2022 en
2023 plus le marché de l'énergie qui
fait qu'ils aient quitté une connerie
monumentale un péché originel à
l'échelle de l'europe enfin prétendre
créer un marché sur un bien
l'électricité par exemple ce qui ne peut
pas se stocker dont qui demande un
ajustement permanent entre l'offre et la
demande entre une offre qui réclame des
investissements massifs et une demande
qui est forcément que n'importe qui peut
faire gérer par par la spéculation on en
arrive on arrive à ça aujourd'hui on en
arrive à huy un déficit de production
d'énergie alors même que la france avait
basé le peu de concurrence en matière
industrielle qui lui restaient sur un
coût de l'énergie très faible pour ces
industriels donc oui ballon paye les
pots cassés décision enfin l'ukraine la
guerre en ukraine tout ça c'est fin
c'est de la poudre aux yeux la guerre en
ukraine n'est que le révélateur d'une
absence totale de stratégie à l'échelle
de l'europe à l'échelle de la france
depuis 30 ans et n est pas responsable
maintenant tout cas pas elle seule mais
n'ont pas eu le solde sur le risque
existe
même quand même un peu pour cet hiver
faut quand même se rendre compte que
chaque hiver on a des risques en quoi
sur quelques journées on a des risques
notamment en bretagne qui souvent moins
bien alimentés que le reste de la france
dire qu'il n'ya pas de risque de black
out ce serait faux après il ya deux
énormes incertitudes dont une qu'on ne
maîtrise pas du tout qui s'appelle la
température ça me paraît complètement
absurde de dire ça mais si l'hiver est
très froid oui là ya des risques de
black out si l'hiver est relativement
dans la norme on doit effectivement
réussir à peu près à passer en ajoutant
plus qu'à l'accoutumée des gestes de
sobriété donc en mettant les chauffages
de façon moins élevé en faisant tourner
des machines à laver la nuit enfin bon
plein de gestes de bon sens qui peuvent
paraître idiot si on les fait
individuellement mais collectivement
c'est important surtout si on rajoute à
ça des gestes qui peuvent être
importants de gros industriels qui
prennent beaucoup d'énergie et qui
peuvent du coup aussi en utiliser un peu
moins attentes et donc il ya
effectivement un risque de black out
j'ai le premier la première incertitude
c'est la température et la deuxième
parce que effectivement comme le dit mon
voisin à la guerre en ukraine est un
élément amplificateur mais le vrai
problème aujourd'hui c'est que nos
centrales nucléaires sont en majorité à
l'arrêt alors pdf à fixer un calendrier
de remise en route d'une part 30
aujourd'hui bien malin celui qui est
capable de vous dire comment ils vont
tourner à quelle puissance et qu'elle
sera vraiment la puissance qu'on aura au
pire moment et le vrai problème de notre
souveraineté énergétique c'est celui ci
c'est le problème de nos centrales
nucléaires aujourd'hui puisqu'il ya un
problème dit de corrosion sur une partie
de nos centrales c'est un peu la faute à
pas de chance mais malheureusement la
faute à pas de chance elle tombe au pire
moment c'est au moment où là on a besoin
de nous de notre capacité pleine et
entière on va parler des conséquences
pour les collectivités d'abord on va
voir avec vous à l'ess les chiffres
combien ça coûte 7 des prix d'énergie
aux collectivités combien en rien si on
regarde l'année 2021 le coût de
l'énergie pour toutes les collectivités
locales s'élève à 4,4 milliards d'euros
et en 2022 avec la flambée du prix de
l'énergie et bien ces dépenses devraient
osciller entre 7 et 8 milliards selon
une estimation de la banque postale
publié au début de l'été alors une
hausse conséquente qui est supportable
pour l'instant par les collectivités qui
mais qui ne le serait pas si ça se
prolonge sur les années suivantes on va
regarder maintenant comment se répartit
cette dépense d'énergie sur les
collectivités et ce n'est pas une
répartition égale puisque 69 % de la
facture énergétique est payé par les
communes
21 % par les groupements de
collectivités comme les
intercommunalités 8% par les
départements et seulement 3 % par les
régions et quand on fait la moyenne des
dépenses d'énergie par habitant chaque
année on voit aussi qu'il ya des
disparités une commune en moyenne
dépense 44 euros par habitant et par an
le département 5 euros et la région 2
euros et alex être acteur énergétique
elle est inégale en fonction de la
taille des communes oui en fonction de
la taille des communes on voit que ce
sont majoritairement les communes entre
3500 habitants et 30000 habitants c'est
à dire les petites villes qui paye la
plus grosse facture énergétique en
moyenne 48 euros par habitant chaque
année ses 10 euros de moins par exemple
que les grandes villes de plus de 100000
habitants donc ce sont ces petites
villes qui vont être le plus impacté par
ces par cette flambée des prix de
l'énergie merci pour les chiffres alex
vous allez continuer à nous donner
d'autres informations emmanuel est ce
que les collectivités locales les avait
suffisamment dissipées cette hausse est
ce qu'elle pouvait l'anticiper ou pas
non elles ont pour la plupart mais pas
plus que nous les ménages plus que les
entreprises cirque on est quand même
dans quelque chose qui était certes
prévisible sur le long terme mais dont
l'ampleur et le choc ne pouvait pas
avoir été imaginé ne serait-ce qu il ya
un an un an et demi on pensait que le
cowitz était conjoncturelle que la salle
et se régler et la guerre en ukraine
plus nos problèmes de centrales c'est
ajouter à tout cela donc non et
collectivités sont dans une situation
inextricable parce que peut-être vos
téléspectateurs le savent peut-être
mieux que les autres mais au total je
parlais de boucliers tarifaire le
bouclier tarifaire c'est pour les
particuliers c'est pour les très petites
entreprises et c'est pour un nombre très
limité de toutes petites communautés de
ville mais pour de toutes petites
communes donc les entreprises les
collectivités sont logés à la même
enseigne elles sont elles face à une
hausse des tarifs ce qu'elles n'ont pas
les fameux tarif réglementé de l'énergie
qui nous permette d'avoir ce bouclier
tarifa donc oui je regardais là quelques
chiffres avant de venir selon
l'association des petites villes les
dépenses énergétiques ont progressé de
plus de 50% selon la ms entre 30 et 300
pour cent selon certaines communes et
selon intercommunalités de france et
trois quarts des communes qui ont vu au
moins deux blé leur facture
d'électricité sont très bons rapports du
sénat si vous avez besoin d'aller loin
alex est peut-être
justement ce rapport qui a été publié à
la fin du mois de juillet par la
délégation du sénat aux collectivités
territoriales et les sénateurs font
plusieurs préconisations sur ce sujet du
coût de l'énergie pour les collectivités
d'abord ils demandent à l'état
d'augmenter la dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est à la dotation
versés chaque année par l'état aux
collectivités
ensuite il souhaite un retour à ces
fameux tarifs réglementés de
l'électricité
il souhaite un retour à ses tarifs pour
toutes les collectivités puisque
aujourd'hui seuls les très petites
communes ont accès à ce tarif réglementé
et les autres les autres collectivités
sont soumises aux fluctuations du marché
et enfin ce rapport du sénat préconise
que des f qui est producteur
d'électricité est bien amorti davantage
le prix l'énergie qu'elle vend aux
autres fournisseurs d'électricité à les
sénateurs demandent donc un nouvel
effort de la part d'edf et donc au final
de l'état qui est actionnaire maintenant
à 100% de l'électricien utilité on
retrouve bien seul face à cette hausse
des prix de l'énergie ouais ouais enfin
ils ont encore des armes pour agir c'est
50% du budget électricité d'une ville
c'est l'éclairage urbain c'est la nuit
les villes ont la possibilité d'avoir
ont plein de au plein de toiture par
exemple sur les gymnases sûr sûr sûr les
centres commerciaux elles peuvent les
équipes et elles peuvent obliger ou
aider à les équiper de panneaux solaires
de chauffage collectif après ensuite une
question d'animation les gilles son
partenaire subventionne en grande partie
des collectivités les espaces info
énergie eie autre agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat que personne ne
connaît en france qui sont des services
publics d'audits énergétiques des aides
à la rénovation énergétique gratuit qui
ont été regroupés dans le réseau france
rénove depuis le 1er janvier par l'
agence nationale de l'habitat
et puis elles peuvent pour certaines
j'ai un exemple d'un hameau dans la
région dans le département du
puy-de-dôme hazell huguet qui a réussi
l'exploit de créer un réseau de chaleur
collectif au bois uniquement local là où
c'était impossible à faire a priori oui
elles ont des armes mais pas tant que ça
ça coûte très cher de toute façon
l'énergie coûte cher et changer de
sources d'énergie ou inciter à
l'économie coûterait cher et comme on
s'en aperçoit dernier moment alors que
c'est des choses qui auraient dû être
prévu il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans pas
beaucoup de weeds collectivités comme
beaucoup de ménages se retrouvent au
pied du mur ouais on va voir un autre
exemple justement puisque vous êtes des
exemples de collectivités qui ont trouvé
des solutions sandra cerqueira va nous
emmener à dents sur meuse grâce à sa
centrale hydroélectrique dun sur meuse
est la première commune de lorraine à
pouvoir auto consommer l'électricité
produite sur place les habitants
pourront donc moins cher leur
électricité en regarde
dun sur meuse est la première commune de
lorraine à utiliser l'électricité
produite par son barrage pour alimenter
les bâtiments publics donc on a trois
génératrices de 200 kilowatts heure pour
une production annuelle de qui varie de
1300 ha
à
et avec la flambée des prix de l'énergie
le maire pierre plots nerveux désormais
que la force de l'eau profite aux 700
habitants de sa commune mais on a mis en
service une troisième génératrice qui va
produire une énergie complémentaire
cette énergie plutôt que de la vendre à
l'autre bout de la france on va mettre
en place l'autoconsommation collectif
c'est à dire que les habitants de la
commune vont pouvoir consommer l'énergie
produite dans la commune ça sera
compétitif pour les habitants puisque
prix de l'énergie a connu une flambée et
que notre coût de production maintenant
est
inférieur au prix actuel marché pour les
gens ainsi dès janvier 2023 les
habitants pourront bénéficier de
l'énergie produite et l'acheter à 8,5
centimes environ le kilowattheure contre
11 à 17 centimes sur le marché actuel de
l'électricité
pour blandine et bruno biz installé sur
la commune depuis de nombreuses années
cette initiative est une opportunité
unique voie la revue c'est vrai qu'on
sent de plus en plus d'électricité et ça
peut être
moi je pense que c'est une bonne chose
ce serait une étude de pouvoir rejeter
la facture et ce serait déjà le fel
le montant de leur facture d'électricité
n'a cessé d'augmenter et payer le
kilowattheure près de 8 centimes d'euros
leur permettrait de faire des économies
non négligeables à l'année ils ont déjà
fait leurs calculs
404 euros
passerait 2250 avis aux
enviro ce qu'on va avoir la maîtrise des
coûts de la consommation
par nous mêmes par la commune ça va il
gérait ce fonds sera tranquilliser de
squatters le maire reçoit chaque jour en
mairie des demandes habitants intéressés
par le dispositif et ne compte pas
s'arrêter là il travaille sur d'autres
projets pour produire de l'énergie
notamment l'installation de 200 mètres
carrés de panneaux photovoltaïques sur
les toits municipaux toujours vous
rendre aux habitants des communes dans
l'auto consommation collective la
commune doit être un élément de
production d'énergie localement il faut
reprendre la main sur ces voix-là son
avenir et pierre ploner espère créer des
émules et susciter des vocations au sein
des collectivités voisines pour que se
développe davantage l'auto consommation
d'énergie dans la meuse on voit entrer
dans les camps plusieurs exemples cités
cet exemple à d'un sur deux est ce que
finalement cette crise énergétique c'est
aussi une opportunité pour les
collectivités d'être plus inventifs dans
la façon dont elles produisent de
l'énergie aie dont elle aurait la
console a bien sûr être avantageux plus
en plus l'intérêt c'est c'est moins
d'avoir un prix de l'énergie moins élevé
c'est surtout d'avoir un prix l'énergie
quasiment constant parce que la commune
on a la maîtrise le seul problème c'est
le coût d'investissement par le coût
d'investissement et des prises en charge
par par edf par exemple mais dans ce cas
là vous revendez l'électricité d'abord
edf et le surplus éventuellement vous
l'injecter sur le réseau local
mais si ça marche pas si la commune n'a
pas les moyens faciles à comines a les
moyens de le faire elle peut très bien
faire ce qu'on a vu à dun sur meuse
messier n'a pas les moyens de le faire
bah finalement il ne fait que 4 un
producteur d'électricité qui alimente le
réseau et pour les habitants il y aura
pas forcément de bénéfices encore une
fois ça la question de l'investissement
initial il faut aider ces communes à cet
investissement qui est très lourd l'a
relevé taz monsieur un peu renseigné
l'investissement était déjà fait il
était déjà amortis et pour une commune
qui part de zéro même installer des
panneaux solaires sur un gymnase sur sur
l'hôtel de ville c'est compliqué c'est
cher sauf si c'est pris en charge encore
une fois par un fournisseur d'énergie ou
par edf et dans ce cas là vous ne pouvez
pas vous votre électricité à bas prix à
vos concitoyens
oui effectivement et on peut trouver
comme ça plein d'exemples isolé mais
malheureusement ça restera isolé je
pense malgré les prix de l'énergie déjà
pour une raison toute simple cercle que
ces désinvestissements qui coûte cher et
qui doivent donc est amorti sur
plusieurs années donc il faut pouvoir le
lancer et que surtout si tout le monde
voulait le faire en ce moment il ya tout
simplement pas la disponibilité et des
entreprises et des produits des
matériaux pour pouvoir mettre tout ça en
place en france en même temps en
revanche ça montre qu'il ya de bonnes
idées et qui peut y avoir d'autres idées
par exemple sûrement qu'on peut acheter
de l'aîné de l'énergie de l'électricité
ou du gaz en commun quand on est des
collectivités de communes quand on est
des choses comme ça et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que chaque crise
apporte quand même finalement des choses
positives derrière et donc ça oblige les
collectivités à se poser une question
qu'elle avait un peu oublié ces
dernières années ce que l'énergie était
à des tarifs relativement absorbable
pour elle donc ça va sûrement accélérer
la mutation qu'elle aurait dû dans tous
les cas engagées pour les années à venir
et c'est peut-être là la seule vertu
pour le moment qu'on peut voir
au côté extrême de la crise actuelle
voilà il ya quand même une inquiétude en
or beaucoup de collectivités évidemment
et notamment dans les territoires de
montagne on va aller aux orres dans les
hautes-alpes on retrouve le maire de la
commune pierre vollaire merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous merde et or est
également vice-président de l'aisne sm
l'association nationale dès maires des
stations de montagne racontez-nous
monsieur muller la conséquence concrète
de ces hausses de prix pour votre
commune et est ce que vous êtes inquiet
puisque la saison d'hiver va s'ouvrir
est-ce que les stations pourront ouvrir
ont bien écouté souhaitant ardemment
effectivement le l'augmentation du prix
de l'énergie aujourd'hui on avait un
prix d'énergie à 58 euros 50 mégawatt
heure on a aujourd'hui des prix qui
oscillent entre 500 et 600 euros le
mégawattheure qui font que on a des
augmentations plus de ces entre x 17 x
13 qui sera effectivement très compliqué
de d'absorber donc nous sommes très
attentifs à ce que le conseil de
l'europe va pouvoir décider
d'eux mêmes puisque s'est réuni sur la
thématique de l'énergie où c'est avec
l'énergie est corrélé totalement la
taille de l'énergie électrique
aujourd'hui à celui du gaz ce qui n'a
présente peu de réalité sur sur le
territoire français en ce qu'il serait
important c'est que ça soit décoré les
qu'on puisse avoir des tarifs maîtrisés
pour qu'on puisse être signer des
contrats puisque nombre de nos stations
sont aujourd'hui
en fin de contrat par exemple ou pour
les autres ça se terminera en novembre
paul hiver et je rappelle que sur les
quatre mois d'hiver nous engrangeons les
recettes qui permettent de faire vivre
nos territoires de montagne à l'année on
a à peu près 300 plus de 3 5 me le roc
emplois directs et induits qui sont
attachés au fonctionnement de nos
stations
voilà donc
décorrélée nous avons rencontré
ministres dont caroline terje dominique
fort mais aussi les cabinets de bono le
maire et de la gloire sur les
possibilités d'avoir quelques aides qui
existent qui ont été peu consommés par
les entreprises aujourd'hui parce
qu'elle était trop complexe
bono le maire a fait passer un un
communiqué de presse avant-hier pour
indiquer que les mesures sont assouplies
donc ça permettra d' art les entreprises
qui consomment plus que 3% de leur
chiffre d'affaires en termes d'énergie
électrique qui ont des postes de charges
de plus de 3% je vois qu'on comprenne
bien que qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans
cet échange ce que vous le dites en vous
avez rencontré les ministres il ya
quelques jours qu est ce qu ils vous ont
dit est ce qu'ils sont prêts à faire des
efforts est ce que l'état est prêt à
vous aider
alors il ya déjà des aides existantes ce
que j'étais en train de vous dire que ce
sera sous pli et qui permettrait
effectivement prendre une grand partie
l'augmentation de ses charges d'énergie
électrique bon ça c'est une solution
mais ce qui est plus important c'est
qu'on puisse retrouver un tarif de
l'énergie décorrélée quand je disais de
du tarif du gaz donc ce qui nous a été
dit on a été très bien reçu par les
ministres par les cabinets sont
parfaitement conscient des
problématiques et je pense que nous
aurons des solutions alors aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas il ya cette solution là qui
est sur la table donc on y travaille en
fait remarquer à la dg fit notamment que
ces aides sont assises sur
les charges d'énergie de 2021 mais on se
rappelle tous que en 2021 aux stations
ont été fermées
de kovy dé consommer d'énergie donc il
faut remettre en place ce mode dead qui
permettrait de passer effectivement
l'hiver de pouvoir ensuite signé des
contrats sur des bases beaucoup plus
solide
vice président de l'association
combien de communes sont concernés vous
êtes vous avez parlé du nombre d'emplois
environ 300 milles combien de communes
sont concernées
écoutez j'aime pas la statistique exacte
de ces stations sont en fin de contrat
mais on pense qu'il y en a au moins un
tiers voire 50% donc le msm rejoint une
centaine de stations en france donc on
pense qu'on en a à peu près une
cinquantaine la difficulté par exemple
pour les or le poste pour nous augmente
de plus de 2 millions d'euros ce que
nous ne savons effectivement pas
honorées on est très engagée d'un
transition écologique toutes nos
stations par exemple aux ont rapporté
programme européen on a abaissé
consommation d'énergie de plus de 20 %
électriques et les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de plus de 100 tonnes de
co2 nous mettant en place des solutions
innovantes nous allons encore faire plus
mais tout ce que nous pouvons faire là
et autour de 10 à 20% alors que l'autre
côté on est sur des augmentations qui
sont à mille trois cent pour cent je
pense que ça ne pourra pas se passer
comme ça aujourd'hui on a des contrats
vrai je ne pense pas que l'opérateur et
df qui est détenue aujourd'hui à 84% par
l'état
équivalent être à 100% d'ici la fin
d'année comprend l'énergie à nos
stations d'un autre côté nous sommes
déjà rigoureux et donc on aime d honorer
nos factures justin derniers mois ça
veut dire que cet hiver il ya des
stations qui pourrait ne pas ouvrir en
raison de cette hausse des prix
je suis pas l'espérer en tout cas on va
tout faire pour les manoeuvres avec mes
collègues de l'année mais s'aiment maire
de la plagne le maire de des deux alpes
et qui j'étais hier à paris et donc
quand on est en est à la manoeuvre pour
faire je pense pas que l'état puisse
laisser je pense que la mesure était
prise du risque alors pour notre station
mais de manière plus générale je pense
que les risques qui sont pour une grande
partie de l'entreprise en france j'ai
les chefs d'entreprise dans d'autres
domaines qui m'ont écouté et qui ont dit
mais on a le même problème que vous donc
la seule bonne solution aujourd'hui
c'est de décorréler le tarif de
l'énergie électrique de celui du gaz je
me répète donc c'est l'europe qui peut
le faire pendant la causerie de l'europe
a su prendre des décisions très rapide
donc j'espère qu'elle va pouvoir prendre
ses décisions et puis ça a été dit mais
on a 32 centrales nucléaires à l'arrêt
sur 56 la moitié pour des opérations
maintenance connues donc j'espère
qu'elles seront remis en oeuvre avant la
fin de l'année et il y en a d'autres qui
sont en mauvais état avec la corrosion
parce que on a délaissé cette industrie
il faut mettre en avant merci monsieur
le maire vous merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous vers deshors 10 président de
l'association nationale dès maires des
stations de montagne merci beaucoup
d'avoir été un mot vous vous en parlais
tout à l'heure c'est derrick may le
maire l'a répété à plusieurs reprises la
solution c'est la décorrélation entre
les prix des lycées abolir ce marché
aberrant qui fait que l'électricité
nucléaire française produite aux frais
du contribuable est largement amortis
est adossé au prix du gaz façonna ça n'a
strictement aucun sens donc
effectivement mais où est ce qu'on va en
arriver là j'en sais rien parce que
c'est un des fondamentaux c'est un des
fondamentaux de l'europe et c'est
évident qu'il faut revenir là dessus
après je reviens tout petit peu sur ce
qu'a dit le maire et notre confrère de
la montagne une solution en france qui
n'est jamais utilisé qui n'est jamais
concerné par les lois de rénovation
énergétique c'est le chauffage solaire
c'est la source fin le dans le budget
des ménages 50% d'énergie c'est le
chauffage en espagne par exemple surtout
de construction note est obligé de
mettre du du chauffage solaire et ça
fonctionne même en hiver même quand il
fait froid ça fonctionne en montagne
c'est idéal ou presque des halles dans
des localités isolées comme le chauffage
collectif dès lors que ces communes se
regrouper en utilisant une ressource qui
passe utilise en france le bois ah oui à
des solutions mais ça réclame des
investissements et puis une aide de
l'état sur ce chauffage solaire qui
n'est pas du tout aidé alors que encore
une fois c'est 50% la facture d'énergie
d'un vrai et la conclusion de ce débat
rappelle manuel on a entendu à lundi
emmanuel macron avec un ponte un ton
très gras mais ce qui les prépare les
français à des lendemains difficiles
oui prépare des français à des
lendemains difficiles parce que il ya
deux axes de lecture avoir serre qui
préfèrent nous dire aujourd'hui fait des
efforts parce que ça va peut-être coupé
et ils seront contents nous dire vous
voyez on avait raison on a tenu donc
vaut mieux prévoir le pire pour qu'au
final derrière ça passe à peu près pour
pouvoir dire tout ça c'est grâce à nous
donc c'est comme ça qu'il faut lire la
déclaration je pense d'emmanuel macron
sur le fait de nous demander de mettre
des pulls à la maison c'est le retour à
la taxe carbone qu'ils veulent il
arrivait bon on aura l'occasion d'en
débattre on imagine merci messieurs
d'abord été si vous restez vous restez
avec nous parce qu'on va regarder la une
de nos quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]